phoenix an all-star back in 2017.  tries for the tie  grizzlies no timeouts 8.9  morant five seconds guarded by butler  jaws scoops and scores with 1.2  to give the grizzlies the lead  another huge stride by morant to be able  to  beat jimmy butler one of the best  one-on-one defenders  to the basket and because brandon clark  is out high  as if he's gonna set the screen there  was no autobio at the basket to be able  to contest  you see here he's able to use his  quickness gets by and then able to  finish  with that left hand duncan robinson has  to clear draugas not a shot blocker at  all and i said brandon clark kept bam  out of bio  away from the basket so no big there to  contest morant  and again how well he does